إضراب في وقت متأخر من الليل في شمال شرق سوريا
هرعت سيارات الإسعاف إلى مكان الحادث مع
اندلاع حريق من مسافة بعيدة ، وضربت الولايات المتحدة
ما يقول المسؤولون إنها
مخازن ذخيرة ومواقع استخباراتية تستخدمها
الميليشيات المرتبطة
بالحرس الثوري الإسلامي الإيراني ، ووصفت الولايات المتحدة
الضربة التي نفذها اثنان من أفراد الحرس الثوري الإيراني.  - 15
مقاتلا عملا متناسبا ومتعمدا
بعد هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار في اتجاه واحد
قتل متعاقدا أمريكيا في وقت سابق
الخميس بالقرب من الحسكة في سوريا وأصيب خمسة من
أفراد الخدمة الأمريكية ومقاول آخر
في الهجوم في ساعة مبكرة من صباح الجمعة في وقت مبكر من
صباح الجمعة تعرضت قاعدة أمريكية أخرى في سوريا
لهجوم من قبل  وابل من 10
صواريخ قال البنتاغون إن الولايات المتحدة
تلقي باللوم على إيران. إيران بالتأكيد
تدعم هذه الجماعات مرة أخرى وبالتالي
تتحمل مسؤولية ضمان
عدم مساهمتها في
انعدام الأمن والاستقرار ولكن من الواضح
أنهم استمروا في فعل ذلك لأن سوريا
أصبحت  مفترق طرق للصراع في
الشرق الأوسط ، نفذ وكلاء إيران
هجمات صاروخية وطائرات بدون طيار ضد
القوات الأمريكية وبدأت روسيا في تحليق
مقاتلين مسلحين فوق المواقع الأمريكية في
البلاد لصالح الولايات المتحدة ، ولا يزال تواجدها البالغ قوامه
900 جندي في سوريا يتركز على
داعش.  من أجل حرب مع
إيران ، لا نبحث عن
نزاع مسلح مع ذلك البلد أو
حرب أخرى في المنطقة ، نسعى لحماية
مهمتنا في سوريا التي تدور حول
هزيمة داعش يوم الخميس ، قال قائد
القيادة المركزية الأمريكية الجنرال إريك
كاريلا.  سمعت لجنة الخدمات المسلحة بالمنزل
أن إيران
ووكلائها أطلقوا طائرات بدون طيار أو صواريخ 78
مرة من القوات الأمريكية منذ بداية عام
2021. هجمة واحدة تقريبًا كل 10 أيام ، فما
تفعله إيران لإخفاء يدها لأنها
تستخدم وكلاء إيرانيين ، هذا
إما طائرات بدون طيار  أو الصواريخ لتتمكن من
مهاجمة قواتنا في العراق أو
سوريا ،
فهذه أعمال حرب من قبل
إيران
يقوم بها
وكلاء إيران ، وهو ما أقول لك عضو
الكونجرس إن الولايات المتحدة نفذت
هجمات ضد وكلاء إيران في سوريا
من قبل  استهداف
البنية التحتية للعدو أو مركبات الإطلاق المستخدمة
لمهاجمة القوات الأمريكية ،
كان هناك نوع مماثل من التصعيد
وضربات وهجمات ذهابًا وإيابًا
في أغسطس ، وبعد ذلك قال مسؤول أمريكي إنه
يعتقد أنه تمت
استعادة الردع ومن الواضح أن هذا لم يعد
هو الحال في هذه المرحلة.  السؤال كيف
تستمر إدارة بايدن
في الرد وهل تعتقد في
وقت ما أنه من الممكن استعادة
الردع هذا هو التصميم الذي
تحتاجه إدارة بايدن لجعل
عاملاً رئيسيًا واحدًا تتذكره هنا في
بداية الإدارة عندما كان عليها ذلك
التعامل مع هذه الأنواع من الهجمات
من الوكلاء الإيرانيين ، كان هناك
صفقة إيران والمفاوضات المحتملة
حولها للنظر في ذلك إلى حد كبير بعيدًا عن
الطاولة والذي قد يفتح
خيارات بايدن فيما يتعلق بكيفية
الرد على هذا وما يجب فعله في
المستقبل